the biggest change we implemented was in
the fall of 2015 we introduced this new
core education which really aims to
develop students as a you know holistic
manner as scholars professionals global
citizens and engage citizens and as well
as people with a sense of wellness and
balance so it's a really holistic sense
of education as opposed to just looking
at the academic or scholarly side of of
an education we introduce students to
the core curriculum starting an
orientation actually they take our
first-year seminar course called Eureka
discovery and its impact and so it's
really about not just scientific
discoveries which is what a you know
again connects a lot of us its
scientists but those personal
discoveries of really finding that aha
moment as to what what drives you and
what makes you happy and successful in
your personal and professional life a
lot of our students obviously have been
very successful coming in to Carnegie
Mellon and so sometimes in their first
semester they aren't quite sure why
we're talking about some of this
information in terms of how to be
successful when they've all been
successful their entire lives basically
and so it's until they start to hit
those tougher classes in their their
sophomore you know second and third
years in college that they really see oh
the you know this is important for me to
understand study skills which is another
area we talk about in the first-year
seminar or you know it's really
important for me to start connecting
with my community because I need I need
to draw on them for support so it's it's
the upper-class students are really
appreciating now the value that they got
out of some of those discussions in the
first-year seminar course both
prospective students and parents are
really excited to see that we're taking
this approach it's a very unique
approach to general education for
science students in America and around
the world in general as I said most
people are mostly focused on the
scholarly aspects and academic aspects
as opposed to thinking about the fact
that everything you do outside of the
classroom is just as important in your
development and can lead to professional
opportunities and changing your
interests and career trajectories and
things like that so so we've we've
brought that all together to get our
students to really think about how
everything they do in their
I'm as a Carnegie Mellon student can can
help them to develop and be more
successful in the future